enjoy now by the former conservative
Minister Audrina curry who's appeared on
Strictly Come Dancing and wife swap and
Christine Hamilton the wife of former
Tory MP Neil Hamilton who finished third
in the very first series of I'm A
Celebrity
Adrina - you first should she be she
should be doing it I don't think so I
must say I'm looking at her chairman
there who clearly a bit too teed off
about the whole thing he didn't even
know she was in Australia but as
constituents there say she's got a job
to do but more than that if Nadine
seriously thinks that they're going to
allow her onto national TV on a game
show like this talking about abortion
she's got another thing coming it'll be
entirely up to the editors how she is
portrayed and it won't be as a champion
of anything do you think that's a fair
point Christine that possibly she's a
little naive about how much of her
politic she's going to be able to get
across when you're in there well
apparently she's never seen the program
so I don't know it's a very very
high-risk strategy for her in the short
term she's going to get nothing but the
probiem from most quarters and i think
most people will will not be positive
about it in the long term if she does
well but that is so high risk for him
take the Gillian McKeith for example
disaster some people come out of it well
it did mean no end of good I mean it
changed people's perception of the sort
of person that I was so it was one of
the best decisions that I had ever made
in my life but only time will tell you
are under scrutiny for 24 hours a day
and it is as the Drina said it's all in
the editing and what I bet is that the
public are going to be voting as soon as
they possibly can to get her she's going
to be one of the prime candidates for
trials very early on I don't know who
else is in there of course there may be
even primer candidates but she's it's a
it's a it's a big risk but she of course
is faintly semi-detached in the Tory
Party so she doesn't worry really what
they do a program like this then you
have to do something wholesome in it
like like cook as you did or dance as I
did and then and also you have to enter
into in a spirit of fun if you go in
there with your ego waving it's going to
be the first thing that the editors will
cut down but what she's justifying how
she trying to justify this that she's
going to be bringing politics to people
who don't possibly engage well she isn't
that is a big big big mistake because
these are entertainment
program so one of the key things that
doesn't happen there is politic she's
making the same mistake with George
Galloway made and he had just lost his
parliamentary seat when he thought he
was going to talk about Iran and the
Middle East and he ended up in a cat
suit
licking milk from the lap of Rula lenska